[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Hi, everyone.
I'm here to talk to you today
about Procurement Document AI.
Does your business have a
lot of receipts and invoices
that you have to
do manual work for?
Do you hate having to type in
every expense for your expense
reports?
Automate it with Google's
Procurement Document AI.
So what is Procurement
Document AI,
and what's the AI part of it?
This is a solution
that allows you
to turn unstructured content
into structured data.
Procurement DocAI has a tooling
for the procurement lifecycle.
So whether you have
handwritten receipts
you need digitized, utility
statements, invoices
with coffee stains,
purchase orders, credit
and debit statements, this
DocAI has got you covered.
How is this smart?
Why wouldn't I just use OCR?
Well, this solution
has specialized parsers
for specific document
types, as mentioned before.
This service cleans your images
and uses Google Vision OCR
to extract the text,
then understands
the structure of the document
sections, like forms, table,
bar codes.
Next, the word, text,
and visual elements
are used for classification
when required.
Google uses an ensemble
of natural language models
to extract entities.
So here, it understands
your line items
and all the information
related to it.
When entities are related,
they are grouped together here.
For example, let's
look at this line item.
We're able to detect the related
fields, such as unit price
and quantity.
They're all grouped
together in the response.
What can you do with it?
Once your data is
structured, you
can easily integrate into
your own app or database,
or use one of ours, such
as BigQuery or Firestore.
Then for everyone doing
analytics out there,
you can visualize it with tools
such as Looker or Data Studio.
I actually decided
to use some code
to inspect my invoices
in a Google Sheet.
I started by uploading my files
into Google Cloud storage,
then wrote a script to extract
a few of the entity types
I cared about and output
them into my tracker.
I can also inspect
individual documents
with my processor in the
Document AI platform.
What was really
helpful for me is
that it normalized
the amounts and dates,
so it was much easier to
work with programmatically.
Now that I have
my data extracted,
I can make charts to
summarize my expenses
or automate them into a report.
So why should I use it?
You can increase
operational efficiency
by reducing manual data entry,
improve customer experience,
and inform decision-making.
Now you can bring the
power of Google AI
to your business's
procurement lifecycle.
I hope we enticed you to check
out this new part of the Cloud
Document AI family.
You can get started today
with Procurement Document
AI in the Cloud Console.
Let us know what
you plan to build.
Happy processing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]